Now the last thing I think I really want to mention
and it really does belong in this lecture
is the affect of market type on revenue.
This is really interesting, because you might have heard about startups
about something called the hockey stick,
and the hockey stick is actually this kind of curve.
Now, it turns out that what the hockey stick really represents
are startups in a new market. Wow. That's kind of interesting. Why?
Well, if you think about it, in a new market on year 1
you have no customers, and so your revenue is essentially flat.
In year 2, revenue still might be flat.
Year 3, it might be flat.
Year 4, oh my gosh, something changed about the market.
There might be a tipping point, an inflection point,
where sales literally go exponential and start to skyrocket.
What happened is a market that didn't exist all things have just come together,
and it's become the year of online education,
or it's become the year of the network,
or it's become the year of the mobile phone or smart phone.
The unfortunate part is most startups that are in a new market
see something that looks like this and go out of business.
What we're really hoping for is that we could influence and affect
this tipping point by our customer strategies, our value proposition,
and our get, keep, and grow strategies.
But the key idea is we want to hoard as much cash as we can,
because almost no startup in a new market can affect the diffusion of innovation by itself.
Other things need to happen.
By the way, this little bump in year one—
this represents the fallacy in new markets.
In almost every new market you could find crazy people just like you
who'd be happy to buy one for their lab or their home.
Such early adopters—they want to have one.
Startup founders look at that curve and say, "Look! It's just going to look like this,"
and start scaling their sales and marketing and spending and then it all collapses again,
because it really was an early adopter sign, not mainstream adoption.
We want to be careful about what our sales curve looks like.
Now, what's really interesting is if we're an existing market—
and remember, in an existing market what do we know?
Well, there are customers and there are competitors.
What we have if by our definition a better or higher performance product
on axes that the customers have defined.
Our job in an existing market is simply year-after-year,
if we execute pristinely, simply to take share away from the incumbents.
So, our sales curve in an existing market literally should be one of taking shares.
Finally, in a resegmented market, this is kind of a hybrid of both new and existing.
What's happening in years 1, 2, 3, etc, in the early days
is you're actually getting revenue from the existing markets.
That is, people might actually kind of find you are an okay substitute,
but really don't understand your unique value
until some tipping point where they realize, oh my gosh, you're just not another vendor
in an existing market, you actually solve better a set of needs for a niche
or you're a low-cost supplier that really makes you unique and special
and revenues take off.
And so what you have to do is husband your cash but not as much in a new market
and figure out how to get you differentiated from the mainstream in existence.